i i love racing i love training as well
which i think is a huge bonus
and and i have a an incredibly
supportive family behind me and two kids
who absolutely love being at races as
well
so i think um yeah i'm very fortunate
but i've also it's incredibly hard
and i know obviously you would have been
watching the olympics how have you found
it watching it in tokyo
well that's one of those strange things
about preparing for three events at the
paralympics is you only get
a small amount of a snapshot and you
focus on events that are potentially
going to help you with your preparations
so
i was immersed in the road events i've
followed as many track events as i can
but i haven't been able to watch it
wall-to-wall as perhaps i would have
liked to and i would have done as a
child
and so i'm very excited to get out to
japan and to see it all for myself
obviously this game has been set up you
know
with a backdrop of very unusual
circumstances we have covert 19 to
contend with here
do you have any worries at all any
concerns at all going to tokyo with that
i think um as craig spence said um and
as was said
uh in the report before you know there's
a bubble being created
for the athletes and the coaching staff
and anybody who's within
you know a touching distance of athletes
on a regular basis
and that bubble protects not just the
people within it but also the people
outside of it
and we're tested every day so i tested
yesterday and i'm now tested every day
right the way through to the day of
departure
and all of those tests will make sure
that if there is any infection it gets
picked up at the earliest opportunity
and we've been following some incredibly
strict rules ahead of going to the games
my whole family are back in quarantine
we have been for um just
over a week now and we're doing
everything we can before we leave to
make sure that nothing gets on the plane
with us
so there's a huge amount of commitment
not just from the athletes and the staff
going
but also from the families who are
supporting us to depart from the country
as well
now you first went to the paralympics in
1992 as a swimmer
you've since switched on to cycling
which we'll touch on very briefly later
on but
firstly i just want to know from your
point of view how has the games
changed over the years
well my first games in 92 was a the
games before any digital media
so you found out you were selected um
because a letter dropped on your doormat
i think people found out in the
newspaper on the news
on teletext there wasn't you know all
the digital platforms to find out team
news
and finding out information about the
games was very different as well
um and but the games was no less
inspiring or exciting and i remember
going to
barcelona and yeah i've not even got
started my gcse courses
and but it was just the most immense
festival of sports and that stayed with
the games all the way through
the past seven games that i've done and
will ultimately stay with us through
into the games in japan as well
celebration of the best athletes in the
world coming together
every four or five years as it is on
this occasion to just perform to the
very best of their ability
and to put all the hard work onto that
playing field onto that race performance
and to see you know who comes out on top
and just very quickly then how did you
make that transition
from um swimming to cycling
well i started by going down to the
manchester velodrome to ride on the
on the track in what they call a taster
session and i think you could do that in
any velodrome in the country we've got
five indoor velodromes
and a number of outdoor velodromes so
you go to a public session you learn to
ride on the track
um and then i um decided that i was
gonna start racing on the track
i became the first athlete within the
talent transfer program
so after racing successfully at the
european championships on the track in
2005
i was offered a place to start with the
bushy cycling program the following year
and so it gave me an opportunity to
decide did i want to go to the home
games in london as a summer
because we knew about those games from
you know july the 6th in 2005
um or did i want to move into a
different sport and try and
make you know break new barriers and
make new ground
and so it was a big decision it was a
hard decision but i think the work ethic
i've brought with me from the swimming
pool
has kind of really set me up to to
flourish on a bike um and the last three
games and now going into tokyo
um it's obviously being all about
pedaling and two wheels
and going to tokyo you're going to your
eighth games is the excitement still the
same as it was for you
back in 1992 oh very much so i sometimes
have to pinch myself to to realize that
i have i'm old enough to go to eight
games
um but yeah the the thrill of pulling on
the british track suits
um i've been able to represent your
country of knowing how many people
uh back home are supporting you and
obviously since the advent of the
national lottery program
you know every day that someone buys a
lottery ticket they're helping to
contribute to the success
of the individuals who compete in the
teams who compete out at those games
and the competitions in between so you
kind of really feel that going with you
and i think that will be even more so
this time round because we won't have
any people
with us on the ground as it were they'll
all be supporting from back home
and but they'll be with us as very much
in spirit as everyone has been
who's been a part of that process since
the program started